bonsoir françois créé mon ski merci
d'être avec nous en direct sur rt france
avoir finalement la france qui avance
sadate en quelque sorte sous la pression
de l'allemagne peut-être c'est une bonne
chose il faut s'en réjouir ou au
contraire il fallait peut-être prendre
davantage le temps comme le disait
certains députés dans l'hémicycle que
cet après midi non moi je pense qu'il
faut au contraire s'en réjouir plus tôt
on pourra commencer les campagnes
vaccinales plus tôt on pourra espérer
voir une sortie de de cette épidémie et
surtout plus tôt on pourra protéger les
personnes les plus vulnérables
donc autant commencer dès que possible
d'autant que ce sera après tout de même
un certain nombre de vérifications
on a parlé de l'autorisation de mise sur
le marché par par l'ime inquiets
l'agencé du médicament européenne et qui
quand même va être en charge de
contrôler les études qui ont été
réalisées sur les vaccins dont des cures
à leur accord on peut quand même se dire
qu'il ya un minimum de risques seront
pas dire aucun risque a lancé cette
campagne vaccinale dans le même temps
c'est vrai que quand on interroge les
directeurs des états non nous dit voilà
on n'est pas complètement prêt on sait
que les pensionnaires des ehpad vont
être les premiers vaccinés parmi les
prioritaires avec les soignants cette
première vaccination se fera un petit
peu pour la photo pour la communication
il fallait dans les temps ont finalement
ça n'a pas tant d'importance que ça
l'essentiel c'est de commencer
l'essentiel c'est de commencer sans
discussion possible
aujourd'hui on voit les difficultés fin
là on a passé un pic épidémique
on est toujours sur une phase de plateau
qui est plutôt bas mais qui reste
présent on craint une reprise tout comme
l'allemagne a connu on a un
déconfinement qui est
qui est un peu entre deux c'est à dire
que voilà on a un peu plus de souplesse
mais on comprend qu'il fallait maintenir
un certain nombre de mesures pour éviter
une nouvelle flambée donc là où on va
passer des fêtes a la chance de pouvoir
quand même faire souffler un peu au
moment de noël d'avoir une possibilité
de voir des mesures et en respectant les
gestes barrière certes un certain nombre
de nos familles on remet un petit peu
une barrière au moment du nouvel an ce
qui est ce qui est bien c'est qu'on va
pouvoir le plus vite possible
protéger les plus vulnérables avec avec
ces vaccins et ce qui nous permettra par
la suite de sortir de cette crise vous
en tant que médecin vous allez
clairement le conseiller à partir de
quoi vous allez quand même exigé avant
de lire les milliers de pages d'études
scientifiques qui ont été écrites
justement sur sur les études des
différentes étapes de cette réalisation
de vaccins alors en tant que médecin de
santé publique
j'ai la chance de connaître un peu le
fonctionnement de ces études et des
différentes
agence qui sont en charge aussi de les
contrôler est ce que je peux vous dire
aussi c'est que c'est quand même des
études qui sont qui sont poussés
l'analyse des des données des résultats
est pas est pas donné à tout à chacun il
faudra un certain niveau de
connaissances et de l'expérience pour
pouvoir les analyser
je vais pas vous mentir je n'ai pas lu
la totalité des études concernant les
vaccins mais je sais que ceux qui le
font qui en sont chargées dans les
différentes agences et aussi au
gouvernement
en tout cas dans les ministères eux sont
très capables et sont souvent d'ailleurs
en france on a un pays on ait la chance
c'est d'être très critique sur les
résultats donc très vigilants il ya des
tours de très grandes précautions sur la
mise en place des différents médicaments
et ce sera le cas donc moi en tant que
médecin de santé publique même si j'ai
pas lu la totalité du contenu je fais
confiance en tout cas aux autorités et
aux agences il dit ce qu' il n'y a pas
de danger
j'irai en tout cas dès que je pourrai
puisque je suis pas dans les les
populations fragiles dans le jir et moi
même me faire vacciner sans aucune
hésitation comme je le fais pour toutes
les autres maladies
vous allez devoir attendre comme nous
d'ailleurs le printemps est ce que ce
n'est pas trop tard pardon françois
delfraissy 1 le président du conseil
scientifique nous rappelle justement
qu'il faut rester prudent que les effets
de ce vaccin et bien il faudra les
attendre encore trois à six mois ce
n'est pas un petit peu trop long je
pense qu'il faut aussi il ya un principe
de réalité on a un certain nombre de
doses qui vont qui vont arriver au fur
et à mesure je pense que la stratégie
elle est tout simplement logique et
pragmatiques les plus vulnérables ceux
qui risquent de décéder et qui en plus
de facteurs de risque en premier ceux
qui sont ensuite au contact de ces
personnes plus fragiles en 2d et puis
ensuite on descendant dans le dans le
niveau de risque d'avoir des formes
graves
donc moi ça peut paraître tout à fait
cohérent je vais pas faire preuve
d'égoïsme en me disant je vais protéger
le premier donc il faudrait que j'aie un
vaccin tout de suite
non moi je préfère que ce soit les
grands
ans les personnes âgées ou les personnes
qui ont des maladies graves et qui
lisent de mourir qu'ils soient vaccinés
en premier
après l'idéal évidemment ça a été de
pouvoir vacciner tout le monde le plus
vite possible maintenant il ya des
principes de réalité de production on
fait au mieux au plus tôt on vous l'a
dit dans les dix en début d'interview
dès qu'on allait on commence à
vaccination pour protéger les plus
vulnérables
et puis ensuite on fait en fonction de
ce qu'on peut faire
ma dernière question en attendant il va
falloir respecter les mesures de
restriction l' oms qui aujourd'hui
recommande le port du masque lors des
réunions familiales
une réaction c'est la seule chose selon
vous pour éviter la troisième vague
alors non c'est pas la seule chose et ça
me permet d'insister sûr ce point le
masque c'est pas un terme qui avait
utilisé mais ce n'est pas un totem
d'immunité
ce qu'il faut voir c'est qu'il ya toutes
les mesures barrières sont utiles pour
continuer à lutter contre la propagation
de cette épidémie
donc évidemment le masque en fait partie
le masque c'est pas encore une fois une
protection individuelle c'est une
protection collective c'est à dire c'est
utile si tout le monde joue le jeu et
j'ai l'impression de plus en plus tout
le monde joue le jeu
mais il n'ya pas que cette mesure de
protection il ya aussi le lavage de
mains très régulier et aussi la
distanciation physique pour rappel c'est
minimum 1 m donc après en essayant de
faire au mieux chacun dans son quotidien
en fait on diminue le risque de
contamination et c'est ça le principal
puisque au fond c c'est cette notion de
risque qui est importante c'est pas tout
blanc ou tout noir tout ou rien plus on
applique les mesures plus on fait
attention et avec le vaccin et plus on
s'en sortira collectivement et le plus
rapidement possible
merci beaucoup françois krakowski
d'avoir été avec nous médecins
spécialistes de santé publique merci